moi je dirais d'abord que dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
il y à deux dimensions qui sont plus
graves de mon point de vue que koffi
n'est pas confiné la première dimension
c'est qu'on ne sait plus qui croire
les français sont perdus et ne savent
plus où donner de la tête
tout le monde avance et des certitudes
de guénand on a vu que toutes ces
certitudes se sont écroulés et de qui
que ce soit de quelques punitions que ce
soit et d'où que les personnes et parler
il ya aujourd'hui une perte de confiance
dans la parole à la fois des métiers
dans la parole des politiques et ça les
français le vivre au plus profond depuis
un an
depuis n en soient tous donné la tête et
la deuxième gravité me semble-t-il c'est
derrière cette perte de confiance
l'absence de perspective si nous avions
une perspective de sortie un bout du
tunnel je pense que beaucoup de choses
seraient acceptables mais comme nous
n'avons toujours pas de perspectives il
ya très peu de choses qui deviennent
acceptables
au bout d'un an parce que ça fait un an
quasiment jour pour jour que nous avons
vécu le premier confinement alors après
quand je dis ça je veux pas donner le
sentiment qu'ils aient une réponse
facile avec une baguette magique pour
faire face à la crise ça serait cas
aucun pays dans le monde entier
de qui peut servir de référence beaucoup
ont essayé des choses peu ont démontré
que tout fonctionne et est chez nous y
compris alors acabit le gouvernement est
ce que c'est une solution parce que
quand on est dans l'opposition quand on
n'est pas aux manettes c'est toujours
plus facile de donner le sentiment que
si nous étions justement responsabilité
on faisait ça on ferait ça et puis
effectivement les choses se règlerait
non je crois que c'est compliqué et
quand vous avez utilisé le terme de
paris tout à l'heure pour le pana
république je suis pas très à l'aise
parce que je sais que j'ai critiqué la
position du gouvernement depuis un an et
il y avait de quoi sur les masques sur
les tests le routard l'huma sur les
vaccins donc il ya de quoi critiquer
mais en même temps je me dis que le
présent à un public qui a retardé cette
mesure de confinement qui n'est pas le
confinement première version non il
n'est pas le confinement de 20 versions
qui est une troisième version du conte
qui demandent même si les mots ont du
sens le fait même qu on utilise le mot
confinement est un peu gênant parce
qu'on al'impression donc finalement ils
mettraient massés depuis un an parce que
nous sommes là c'est même un confinement
un peu
ces récents et rapidement que nous avons
vécu mais effectivement nous sommes là
c'est peu de perspectives des certitudes
que l'on ne croit plus et donc les
français ne savent plus où donner de la
tête
eric et la réalité c'est que derrière
cette situation moi je fais 2 costa qui
sont cruels pour le politique et pas que
pour ce gouvernement
pour le gouvernement de rolande fonds le
gouvernement sarkozy d'abord un nous
avions avant la crise 4700 place en
réanimation
au moment où nous nous parlons on en a
pas plus 5000 et le 29 août 2020 il ya
eu une prise de parole d'olivier vers un
public qui a dit que nous pouvions
monter jusqu'à 2000 i aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 4700 et on nous explique que
nous sommes saturés
ça veut dire qu'on ne s'est pas donné de
marge de manoeuvre sur la capacité de
traiter les français et parfois je pense
au personnel soignant
quand je dis ça parce que c'est eux pour
moi à l'esprit ils doivent faire des
choix mais rendez vous compte
ils sont dans une situation de rupture
le personnel soignant et soignantes et
infirmières serré animateurs ils étaient
en grève à la commune personne ne les
regarde et on les a applaudi le soir du
1er confinement donc mais aujourd'hui
leur situation ne s'est toujours pas
améliorée on a tous un entre deux lits
dont un le personnel soignant
aujourd'hui est en rupture et c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'on prend cette
décision aujourd'hui parce qu'il faut
les soulager parce qu'ils n'en peuvent
plus évident parce qu'ils sont obligés
de faire des choix et de faire de choix
à choisir entre des vis-à-vis des
français
la vie de nos compatriotes de gens qui
peuvent nous toucher ils nous le disent
tous
il faut aujourd'hui nous donne un peu de
boxes y en eu peu de respiration un peu
de latitude est fermé pour la question
que vous posez tout à l'heure à quoi
sert un confinement
moi je suis pas un spécialiste avec
beaucoup d'humilité chez un citoyen qui
essaie d'écouter
il me semblait qu'on nous avait expliqué
que le confinement servait à cash à
casser la chaîne de transmission donc en
tout cas la mettre à mal bon pour éviter
effectivement qu l'erea soit donc à bloc
docteur je termine je termine les la
réanimation saturé il fallait faire
quelque chose et deux questions l'échec
de la campagne vaccinale
excusez moi mais aujourd'hui le sco moi
je veux bien qu'on ait des vaccinodromes
je veux bien qu'on mobilise et officiers
nos pharmacies laissa les cent mille
médecins généralistes après jackson n'a
pas accès nous n'avons pas de vaccin
israël pour terminer qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait quand ils ont confiné où ça va
se faire vacciner massivement et quand
on me dit à la population les combats
quant au bâtiment et à la sortie au bout
du tunnel qui s'est passé pour oublier
répondre il n'y a pas de bout du tunnel
c'est ça qui est dramatique